[Applause]
[Music]
here is a question what would you say is
a drug traffickers biggest dream Rome
would blow with Rome Oh Papa Papa Papa
Papa papa dro Gomorrah sex or
pornography go alright allow me to
explain myself because we all have
dreams you me politicians and of course
drug traffickers they are no exception
they are people too
there may be hard to believe in the
heart of the ruthless and cruel drug
trafficking industry there are human
beings with names and in this case also
nicknamed soup just like everyone else
have dreams so let's get back to my
original question what is the biggest
dream that a drug trafficker could have
I mean of course there might be
different possible answers because we're
all individuals but unfortunately
history tells us that if most drug
traffickers could make a wish just one
single wish would be to turn their
country into a narco-state that is to
say they would turn them into States run
by a kind of criminal corporation made
up of politicians public officials
judges the police and the military which
in one way or another were associated
with drugs that way drug traffickers
could basically act with impunity
exporting and distributing narcotics
without any restrictions very recently
here on visual politic we spoke about
how the Bolivarian regime of Nicolas
Maduro Diosdado Cabello and the cartel
De La Hoya's was turning Venezuela into
a narco-state however in latin-american
occupy lytx it goes far beyond Venezuela
in this video we're gonna find out a bit
more about one character who was able to
promote the alliance between the
narcotics industry and politicians so
listen up
[Music]
narcho populism
we all know it the narcotics industry is
one of the most important illegal
businesses every year in moves several
hundred billion dollars now allow me to
ask another question do you think that
are cartel can survive without political
support can they survive without
controlling the institutions in some way
to answer this question let's go back to
the beginning and take a look at how the
most important drug dealers of all time
managed to do it because even though
it's true that in the beginning drug
traffickers started out as little more
than a bands of outlaws the time came
when this all changed a time came and so
did a protagonist Pablo Escobar Gaviria
considered by Forbes magazine to be one
of the richest men of his time on the
entire planet
according to Forbes in 1987 Pablo
Escobar had a fortune that exceeded two
billion dollars and Escobar he radically
changed the global drug industry see on
the one hand he created an entire
network a criminal holding company that
included businesses like extortion
kidnapping murder and of course their
main activity of drug trafficking all
these activities were perfectly
integrated into a structure the Medellin
Cartel which had a clear organizational
chart a well-defined hierarchy and even
a zone based distribution network each
with its own managers talking in
Business Week these were sort of like
franchises or branches on the other hand
regarding his main business drugs this
cartel the Medellin Cartel achieved an
almost complete vertical integration
that is the cartel took over the harvest
the production the distribution in the
marketing of the vast majority of its
merchandise they did everything and they
took over every single stage of the
business
[Music]
that's how the midian cartel managed to
bring in more than 7 billion dollars per
year of course none of this would have
been possible without the complicity of
the public authorities apparently
Escobar reached the top of the cocaine
cartel by astutely reinvesting his
initial earnings and becoming a PR
master in Colombia with his growing
wealth
Escobar bought a newspaper in midian
gained influence in Colombian politics
and he successfully ran for public
office becoming an alternative to the
National Congress David Henry Forbes
magazine 1987 you see for many years
Pablo Escobar had impunity with his
money and threads the well-known phrase
of silver or land he managed to
infiltrate the Colombian State he bribes
the military politicians governors and
the police in such a way that many
Colombian institutions were under his
command for a long time and that's not
all Pablo Escobar also financed
electoral campaigns to win popular
support and what does a politician do
when he wants to gain popularity fast
well he promoted projects like the
building of houses for the nation's
poorest citizens as well as distributing
provisions and creating soccer fields
sounds pretty good doesn't it I mean a
first glance kind of like a Colombian
Robin Hood yeah it seemed bad the truth
was rather different while he was
carrying out this type of campaign he
had no qualms about flooding the streets
with violence and blood
welcome to narco populism as you all
probably know Pablo Escobar managed to
hold a seat in the Colombian Parliament
in 1982 until then thanks to his
political influence and his PR
strategies he was able to build his
empire and his huge fortune with the
utmost impunity a member of the United
States Drug Enforcement Agency once said
that importing exotic animals for his
zoo caused Escobar more problems with
the government than his drug business
David Henry now hold on just a second
don't think the Pablo Escobar's
political relations were limited to
Colombia not at all
you see after being elected as a deputy
the situation it became untenable some
members of the media began telling the
truth behind his fortune the DEA is
pressure multiplied and a lot of
Colombian society understood the huge
danger that Pablo Escobar posed and
other cartels they began to fear the
power that the Medellin Cartel would
grow into that's when the government
began to persecute this capo which in a
way declared war on the Colombian state
itself and just to be safe the first
thing Escobar did was leave the country
lest he be hunted down
[Music]
the leap
so pablo escobar's put some space
between himself and colombia the
question is where could he find refuge
would his drug money be enough to
strengthen his alliances well it seems
absolutely so first of all there was
Panama at that time the military
dictator Manuel Antonio narita offered
him asylum protection and a route to
transport his merchandise so imagine
this industry was so powerful that even
dictators were willing to sell their
services the fact is that as you can see
Narita also turned Panama into a narco
States that is until 1989 when a
lightning invasion by the United States
removed him from power he was detained
taken to the United States and given 30
years in prison for his drug trafficking
and his relationship with a Medellin
Cartel but this this is not the ends of
paulo Escobar's external alliances the
truth is that he didn't feel very safe
in Panama either I mean yes the dictator
of the country was his pal but the CIA
had a very large presence in the country
so when he least expected inner-ear
could be tempted to sell him out because
of course it was one thing to do
business with a Panamanian dictator and
quite another to entrust him with his
protection he needed to find a new
destination so through the left-wing
Colombian guerrilla movement m-19 Pablo
Escobar contacted the Nicaraguan
government other moments the sandanista
government board led by the country's
current President Daniel Ortega was
willing to welcome him with open arms in
exchange for a commission
you know the services rendered the
agreement specified that in addition to
settling in the country with his family
Pablo could use some of Nicaragua as
regions as a drug distribution platform
the problem Ortega and his friends they
were very greedy so a few months later
Pablo decided to return to Colombia but
of course he maintained his business
relations
but there's more along with Nicaragua
the m-19 guerrillas also facilitated the
Medellin Cartel contact with the Cuban
government that's right Cuba was also a
trading platform for Pablo Escobar's
businesses in fact it is known that
Pablo Escobar maintained good relations
with the Castro brothers although
truthfully it seems that he wasn't the
only one all evidence indicates that
after Escobar other drug dealers
continue to use Cuba through the
Castro's to introduce all types of
narcotics into the United States
anyway Colombia Panama and Nicaragua
Cuba as you can see political power was
one of the main drivers of the huge
presence of drug trafficking in Latin
America the lack of transparency the
corruption lack of counterweights and
weak institutions were a perfect
breeding grounds for what over the years
became one of the greater nightmares of
this region and yes some of you might
now be thinking well alright Simon but
in the end Pablo Escobar he fell from
power and yeah it's true but when a man
like Escobar Falls it doesn't mean that
the industry Falls and in all of their
relations with political power let's
have a look at the Mexico
the relay
[Music]
the main Mexican cartel with which Pablo
Escobar had a relationship was the
Guadalajara cartel led by ernesto
fonseca Rafael Caro Quintero
and Miguel and Hal Felix Gerardo this
cartel had full impunity for two decades
all thanks to their relations with
people in power see Felix guy otto was
in charge of public relations and thanks
to his ability to move within the
highest political spheres this cartel
had all the stability it needed to
develop and grow PR is really important
however we're talking about a criminal
industry and in criminal organizations
stability is very hard to achieve in
this case the assaults on the DEA agents
enric a Camarena which ended its life
made Washington demands the dismantling
of this cartel and its leaders fell one
by one but this didn't end the business
from prison in 1989 felix Guyardo tried
to reorganize the territories but in the
absence of an agreement to the cartel it
split into the tijuana cartel led by the
ariana brothers in the Sinaloa cartel
led by Hector Louis Palmer Salazar el
Guero Palmer and Hakeem Guzman Mariah
aka El Chapo they both debuted on the
Forbes list in 2009 with an estimated
fortune of more than 1 billion dollars
the fact is that under El Chapo's
commands the Sinaloa cartel became the
most important and influential cartel in
Mexico and one of the most important
criminal organizations in the world the
question that many of you might be
asking now is how did he do it how can
one cartel grow so much more than its
adversaries what above all it's because
of political influences for example how
do you prevent the federal police from
catching you and dismantling your
business well you would do that by
finding out when those raids are gonna
happen everything is based on good
relations and that's precisely what El
Chapo made sure that he would have
information and friends a power and as
we've seen in other cases El Chapo's
capture it didn't really change the
panorama today the Sinaloa cartel is
controlled by ismael el mayo Zimbardo
who over the years has been owned by
officials from the special prosecutor's
office the attorney general's office and
even the counter narcotics intelligence
center an elite army corps created to
fight narcotics obviously they don't do
these businesses alone in many cases
they have the approval or participation
of the authorities fjr researcher at the
University of Guadalajara this is all
done in complicity with senior
government officials
only that explains these criminal groups
power strength and resilience which
organ about a political power with which
in many cases narcos create a symbiosis
that is hard to distinguish that's
what's happening in Venezuela with a
soulless cartel of which we've already
spoken here on visual politic and watch
out because it's estimated that the
Mexican and Venezuelan cartels control
70% of all drugs that enter the United
States that's what happens in countries
like Guatemala where some sources state
that up to 80% of all the white powder
could be mediated by members of the
national army itself or what's happening
in Honduras where even the son of former
President Porfirio Lobo has been
condemned in the United States for drug
trafficking activities while his own
father was President of the Republic
anyway folks that is the result of
having weak institutions a lack of
transparency and a lack of
counterweights in future videos we're
going to talk more about this issue
which is becoming very expensive for
Latin American countries with this video
we just wanted to show you a few
examples of health some of the greater
narcos succeeded largely thanks to their
influence on established institutions so
I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you next video
[Music]